Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 8th, 2013 how
you doing? How I, yeah.
Uh, today's podcast episode
is brought to you by ting.
Please visit Bill Dot [inaudible] Dot
Com for $25 service credit or device
discount.
That's build dot tain t I n g.com
and I know what you're thinking,
Bill. What the Hell is ting? What is it?
You can't just bring up a product and, and
I don't even know what it is. You know,
it's got that ambiguous name.
What's going on with it?
While Ting is a new mobile service
that brings clarity, usability,
and significant monthly savings to
us small businesses and families.
So basically if you're tired of paying
an arm and a leg for your cell phone bill
every month,
you should check out ting.
They just sat at a new three g slash four
g. Why Max Hotspot to the Ting lineup?
The Sierra wireless overdrive pro can be
had and refurbished for only 30 bucks.
In February,
they added the option to purchase used
devices via their partnership with glide.
The option to bring a sprint
device has been around for a while,
but there was a limitation. No Lte
devices could make the move. Well,
they've been working to have this
limitation removed and now many LTE sprint
devices are able to make the
move to Ting port your home port.
I don't even know what that means.
Port your home phone number to Ting
and save a mint if you like us,
barely use the home phone but
aren't quite ready to let it go.
This $100 device can bridge
the gap and save you a ton.
Verse Traditional Wired
Home Phone Services.
You don't actually might check that out
because I barely use my home phone but I
refuse to give it up.
You know why?
Because I'm part of the old school I am
when I'm on the phone or wear a headband.
You get it. Fucking old school. Sorry. Um,
anyways, they have excellent online
support. Anytime you got a problem,
you can call them at
1-855-TANG-FTW anytime between
8:00 AM and 8:00 PM eastern
standard time.
And believe it or not,
a real person will actually
pick up the phone. All right,
so please visit bill.ting.com for $25
service credit and this device discount.
There we go. I almost got through without
stuttering. All right, so here we go.
This is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody and I am in Atlanta
Hatton and had baby. How you doing?
Um,
I uh,
got here last night. Uh,
I'm a day early before my,
my big show down in
Athens, Georgia. And uh,
you're probably wondering, Bill, why did
you come in a day and a half early? Well,
I'll tell you why because tonight
I'm going to the basketball game.
Michigan Versus Louisville. All
right. The NCAA championship game.
Why wouldn't ya?
You're in town.
Does still tickets to be had.
Could you believe that there's
still tickets we had, dude,
Atlanta has to be the worst fucking
sports town on the face of the United
States. I didn't say the earth. Okay.
I'm not going to be arrogant and act
like I know sports fans from here to
Timbuktu.
I don't even know where Tim Buck two is.
I don't even know if that's
a real fucking place.
I don't know if that's an expression.
I don't know who shot at.
I don't know who's not.
Um,
but they fucking suck here in Atlanta.
Okay. In Atlanta, they
suck George bulldogs.
That's a whole different story you
gave me. No Damn dogs. I'm in there.
I'm between the hedges.
Okay?
I'm not talking about the SCC college
fucking sports fans down here.
Those people are fucking lunatics.
All right?
They're out there making
moonshine before the game.
They're out of their fucking minds.
The read that full on fucking redneck
or they're like that. Um, oh, Belvedere,
they'll come here and all,
they have that fucking plantation vibe.
One of the other, just talking about
the white people down here. All right?
So, and the drug addicts
are all in the waffle house.
All right?
If you want to score some meth and get
a delicious breakfast and you're in the
south, I have to recommend the fucking
waffle house. That's the place to go.
If you'd like to maybe get into a fight.
If you didn't even know that
you wanted to get into a fight,
that's what you want to fucking go.
Waffle houses basically.
That would be the south.
That's Kinda of their end.
What the fuck is the equivalent
to that up in the north?
Just someplace we could go out and get
some food and maybe get the shit kicked
out of you.
Maybe get a prostitute.
Yeah.
Maybe you have a heart attack. What
does that, the cheesecake factory.
You know what? I'll have to get
back to you on that one. Anyway,
so I'm here and I'm going to be going
to the, uh, the basketball game tonight.
What the fuck is what? This chair,
it's one of these fucking chairs.
Oh, I keep hitting the adjustive
thing with my calf. Sorry.
It's not the chair's fault.
It's my fault. All right.
You know what's great about this
chair is it's not a live person,
so I don't really have to apologize to it,
even though I just did it.
This was a woman I have to be like,
you know,
right now she would have her arms
crossed looking out the window. You know,
I just,
I understand that you know,
you have a lot of pressure because
you've been traveling a lot lately. Okay.
But this snapping and,
and just immediately going to
the anger. No, no, let me finish.
Okay. I think you've said enough
for them. Morning. You know,
they just say that shit just
gets you fucking going. I'd
have to apologize to it,
you know, and buy some flowers
by it. Some stuff, you know,
sorry,
chair.
My Midi calf actually was hitting the
adjustment thing, so it wasn't your fault.
It wasn't a design fall flaw or
whatever the fuck I'm trying to say.
What am I trying to say?
I'm trying to say that I'm going to the
NCAA championship came tonight here in
Atlanta and it's not
even fucking sold out.
How fucking hilarious is that?
What is wrong with the city of Atlanta?
You know what it is this too much. This
too much pussy in the city, that people,
they just don't go to the fucking too
much pussy in too much. Jesus. Yeah.
Both sides of the fucking rainbow,
you know?
And they just don't go to the Goddamn
Games was the last time I Braves games
sold out.
You know,
if I ran the Braves,
you know what I would do?
I'd put a fucking stripper pole out
there in the goddamn bullpen, you know,
so the people out here could make it
rain in between innings and then I think
maybe I could get the stadium
half fucking full. Oh,
fuck you.
What the fuck is this?
South Carolina? This is like a fucking
phone or I got to do, I, I'm doing that.
Um, the hell was I titled
the Stripper Pole. Yeah.
Do you know what kills me about
the fucking Atlanta Braves?
Is they still do that
Tomahawk chop that shit.
Okay.
And there's no passion behind it is
ah,
what kind of a fucking asshole does that?
How many tribes have said how
fucking offensive that is?
You know what I mean?
That's what I,
that's when I really fucking hate people
when they're just like, you know, Whoa,
what are the eight got nothing
to do with that. You know,
that's stupid. Just, you know, it's like
people like Erin to the confederate flag,
you know,
and they tried to say that it has nothing
to do with fucking slavery and just
has to do with southern pride.
Give me a fucking break. You know,
just be a fucking racist.
Just man up and be a racist.
Just get a nice fucking swastikas
swastika tattoo right on your forehead.
Stop being passive aggressive.
Probably gonna get kicked out
of this hotel for saying this.
I'll fuck you Steve jobs with your
fucking noises. I heard it. I heard it.
I grabbed the phone.
I fucking reacted to it.
You can't from the gravy,
still a cunt.
I wonder whose idea he stole for that
fucking thing and then passed it off as
his own as he goes out and tries to
fucking levitate with one of those cheesy
fucking magicians.
Okay.
Goddamn fucking phone.
I hate this fucking thing.
You know what kills me too is you
put it on, you put it on vibrate.
I mean there's no way to shut it up.
I'm sure there is.
If I read the fucking manual,
you know,
but I don't have time for that and
read a fucking cell phone manual.
Finally figure the thing out
and then what? It's obsolete.
And eight months bill quit
yelling. You just lazy. All right,
maybe I shouldn't be
going off on the dead guy.
You know that Douche bags on the cover
of fucking Time magazine with like Albert
Einstein as far as people who changed
and shaped the world the way it worked,
this stupid advertising where they lined
themselves up with Gandhi has actually
fucking worked. Cause now the dude's
dead. And on the cover of life magazine,
they had, you know, Jesus didn't even
make the fucking cover or maybe did,
I don't know, but what the fuck, you know?
Okay.
They actually had a really good
picture of Albert Einstein.
They had a younger version of him,
you know,
where his hair wasn't all fucking gray
and he didn't have that sad look on his
face.
You know that look he had on his face
after he fucking showed those psychos how
to, how to blow up all of Japan.
All right. This is the cover.
The cover is Abraham Lincoln. Jesus,
Albert Einstein, Martin Luther King,
the Beatles, Hitler, some old
broad with fucked up teeth.
Uh,
Mother Teresa
fucking a Gandhi. Uh, Jesus.
What the fuck is the name of that guy
who spent all those years in prison for,
in apartheid or whatever the fuck his
name is? Was it William William H Macy?
The fuck is that guy's name.
You finally got out and his wife stuck
by him and then he fucking dumped her.
And then the guy who came up with the
phone that angry look on his face with the
Edison.
Okay,
the fuck is a guy's name here.
Sidney Poitier.
I'm the worst. I don't fucking
know who anybody is. And anyways,
they got Steve Jobs, Steve Jobs, rubbing
elbows with all those fucking people.
Fucking stupid ass God damn nerds.
Cause he did what? He invented a phone.
Did he even invent it?
Having already talked about this
on stage up on this silver screen.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm out here in fucking Atlanta and
I'm going to that Goddamn game tonight,
this stupid concert. They don't even
fucking sell the thing out there.
Still doing that Tomahawk Chop.
Okay.
It's like why? Why, why would you do that?
Yeah,
that and they got the fucking drum.
Bowden Dum, Dum, Dum, Dum, Dum, Dum.
I was just talking about this on
the regular guys morning show.
My brother took a tour one time somewhere
in Arizona and they were talking about
how native Americans played their
drums and they will be like,
they play it like this.
They play it like that.
But at no point did they ever go banner
dump, dump, dump, dump, dump, dump.
That's just some fucking Hollywood shit
where they hired a white guy with the
Tan, maybe have a little
bit of a sunburn, you know,
to give them the reddish tinge that they
thought they, the fucking Indians have,
which I've never understood.
If you see a real native American,
there's nothing read about
their skin, you know, you know,
it was a fucking red skin.
I am God damn fucking redhead.
You put me out in the sun, I will fuck
with any native American. A patchy.
I don't give a fuck who you are.
My skin will be redder than yours.
I should be offended by the Washington
Redskins. They make fun of me, not Yo.
All right. Just the fact that your
face is on the side of the helmet,
that's just a misdirection.
All right?
It's just another group of people
coming at us, fucking redheads,
and you know what? I want to
get sick of it. All right?
I'm sick of conch coming up to me,
telling me that I'm going to be extinct.
Like I'm some sort of fucking white rhino.
You know you're going to do,
you guys are going to be gone by 2040
it's like I'm going to be 72 in 2040 it's
still going to be here. You cunt. You
know why? You know why? I'll tell you why.
Cause they go out to these hotels.
All right. Oh, there's another plane.
Where are those people going?
God,
I always wished I was on a plane
going to some place. Exciting.
Sorry. That was the inner monologue
of a woman who got married at 22. Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
This is why I'm going to live to
be 72 cause I don't stay in motels.
I don't fucking make speeches
about how to change the world,
at least on my podcast. Maybe I do. Okay,
but I'm not standing in front of
fucking a zillion people. All right?
So no one's going to whack me. All right?
I got good genes. And you know what?
Today I go downstairs, they got the
fucking continental breakfast down there.
They've got the breakfast buffet and they
also got the whole thing you can order
from the menu. All right?
And what do I see down there?
I see all the mantated fat fucks who
got the corner office and they're down.
They're getting themselves in the all
American breakfast, two, three eggs,
any style, the fucking bacon,
the potatoes just, well,
you know what they are when they're
fucking grabbing their heart by the,
by the lapels grabbing and just
go, hey mother fucker. Right.
And then just need it. Right. If
they keep, if you're hardhead balls,
that's what you're doing with that
breakfast. The all American, you know,
and I did. I went down there like a
little fucking twinkle toes. All right.
I was up on my,
on my tip toes and I did a little dance
move when I slid into the booth and the
lady,
you know,
the lady came over,
it's a waitress.
Like I think all waitresses
should be female.
Even the waiters.
That's just a broad job.
I'm a hungry man.
I want food to be brought to me.
This should be a woman involved in that.
Okay, I'm traditional. I'm old school.
I pay for the movie.
I want my sandwich made by a woman
that's a man and a fancy hat.
Some poor excuse for a
fucking pope hat dude.
How far down is the fucking Catholic
religion fallen now that we're all over
there, all the way down there
in there, in like south,
they had to leave this country.
They're gradually moving to the
third world just because they,
that's the last place that people are
still believed that some bearded dude on
water. Talk to a fucking
Bush and then, uh, you know,
died and then came back three
days later, you know, Oh shit,
the fire engines are coming up.
I think there's a plane on fire.
That is my big fear.
My big fear is not dying in a plane crash.
It's surviving the plane crash and then
being soaked in jet fuel and burning up,
you know, for a nice four second
death of, and then that's it.
You know, you'd probably be even higher,
much higher pitched. I wonder what the,
I mean,
how many decibels you can,
you can actually create if
you're burning and jet fuel.
It's so fucking terrifying when you go
to takeoff, you literally just, you're,
you're in a tube of gasoline.
Yeah. Belt. We get it.
We understand that you
need a lot of Gath GI bill.
Do you need a lot of gas to fly across
the country while your podcast is so
informative? Oh, so anyway,
so I'm down there and I get
the fucking breakfast. Okay.
And I could've got the fucking three eggs,
any style.
I could've got the pancakes or the
waffles. You know how they do that shit?
When they turned it into a dessert,
they got everything but fucking
chocolate frosting on him now. I said,
fuck all that. And I said to
the lady, I said, you know what,
let me get the cold cereal
cold called like fucking
Margaret Thatcher's knees.
And I'm not saying that
because she's dead. Okay.
That fucking shape shift and rectal,
you know,
I actually think that she's George Bush
like that.
That's like his altar regrow is,
he's actually actually ego ego.
He's actually also Margaret
Thatcher. You know, just the theory,
just something to kick around in a bar.
I think they're all the same person,
you know, and they shoot all the world
leaders all in the same living room.
And uh, maybe it's, maybe
he, he's not a shape shifter,
but he's got some excellent
like Hollywood makeup, you know,
and then like when he was supposed to be
in America and nat can debt, and then,
you know, then when they cut
to him over and fucking be,
and Margaret Thatcher
and he's, oh, Johnny,
he just fucking just changes his voice.
He's like the Mel Blanc of like the
Illuminati. That's what I think.
And I actually voted for the
mother fucker. I liked him. He was,
they supposed to vote for that fucking
squinty Polak fucking riding around in
the God damn tank. Oh, was he a
Greek dude? You guys know Copernicus,
the guy who figured out that the
fucking earth didn't go, you know,
it was going around the sun and that
the sun was the center of the universe.
That guy was a Polak. All
these Polish jokes, you know
Copernicus, that doesn't sound like a
Polish name to me. That sounds Greek.
But I digress. So I go
down there. What do I get?
I get the fucking raisin bran
with the 2% milk there, right?
I get the milk from that cow.
That was probably fed another cow.
So God knows what kind of fucking,
uh, poisons are in me right now.
That's only 2% of it as opposed
to 4%. You understand that, right?
Um,
2% of what I have no fucking idea.
I actually read something one time
or how they do, do the fat count.
It's bullshit. It's kind of like how
they do the gas mileage on the cars.
When they drive the car like two miles
an hour with like a fucking hurricane
wind behind you,
it gets 60 miles a gallon.
Um, and then you get it, you only get
20 and you're like, what the fuck?
They're like, well, you're
stepping on the gas pedal too much,
but how do I make it go without doing
that, sir? Why are you being hostile?
Cause you're a cunt. That's why.
And then you're out of that,
then you're out of the showroom
and that's it. That's it.
Do you ever go into a showroom and you
see the fingerprints on the glass and you
see 1 cent where it's,
they're really indented in the window
and then they kind of slide to the right.
That's the guy who used the c word.
He said cut in the showroom,
then was dragged out. Um, yeah. I
don't know. I'm talking about, so yeah,
so I went with raisin brand,
then I've got a banana,
put it on top and you know what?
I'm fucking full, you know,
filled up the fucking stomach.
And I didn't go down there
and, and, and just, just,
you know,
just starting your day with fucking
1200 calories to your ass and now you're
down to 800 and you know,
you're going to do that at lunch and
then you'd done and then the rest of the
day, all it is, is just fucking overflow
spillage for your fucking arteries.
And you got damn muffin top.
All right.
Why am I yelling at you guys this week?
I don't know. I'm fucking know in a,
I'm in a great mood. I'm going to
go to this fucking game tonight.
It's going to be tremendous. I'm going
to have the whole road to myself. Why?
Because it's a sporting event in Atlanta.
I'm telling you,
if they put stripper poles down there,
they would have fucking sold it out.
And what? It costs me like nine
grand a ticket. Um, so I actually,
I have an amazing week.
I'm going to the basketball game
tonight and then I do a run a theaters.
I'm in Athens, Georgia on
Tuesday. I'm an Alabama,
which Georgia actually looks down on,
which is fucking hilarious.
If you're not from this region,
you know,
it's like you fuckers are
all the same to me. You know?
And I don't mean that in a bad way,
but I don't mean it in a good way either.
Um,
Alabama at the star Dome on Wednesday
and then Thursday I'm over in South
Carolina, South Caca Lackey and then, uh,
no, Tuesday, Athens, Wednesday star Dome,
Thursday South Carolina.
And then Friday I got two shows in Atlanta
and then Saturday I go to the masters.
You see that people,
you too can live the dream when you never
get married and don't have any kids.
You can live selfishly like I do,
you know,
and go to all these wonderful things and
brag about her on your own podcast and
then go to bed at night and cry
yourself to sleep. What the fuck?
I keep hitting this goddamn thing and
this fucking chair, it's driving me nuts.
You know what?
It's almost like the chair knows
my ego's completely out of control.
Just keeps it live. It, let's,
let's bring him down a little bit.
They'll closer to the floor a little
closer to the regular people. All right.
Just to show you what a whore I am.
I'm going to read a couple of a couple
of ads here. Legal Zoom. Everybody.
Do you have a job that you hate?
You know you want to get out of it.
Do you want to start a business?
But you don't want to sound like
you're just starting a business.
You want to sound like you're actually
making money already. You know,
this is what you gotta do. You
gotta go to legal zoom. I'll wait.
That's easy voice with the hell.
Am I talking about?
I can't even keep these damn
things straight. Legal Zoom. Oh,
this is how you set up the, uh, I know
white. This is it, right? Is this it?
Legal? Zoom is the one where you, uh,
you turn yourself into a corporation
right off the bat, right?
But why don't you just read the copy?
You fucking moron. All right, here we go.
Legal Zoom. Everybody. Look, you've got
to plan for your future. We all know this.
You do financial planning, you get
insurance. But to get real peace of mind,
you have to make sure your
family is legally protected. Um,
so where do you turn for
affordable legal protection?
You can trust why legal zoom.com for
over 12 years they've been helping
Americans get personalized wills,
powers of attorney, living trust,
real estate documents,
and more legal zoom also helps start and
maintain businesses with incorporation
and LLC filings, trademarks
and copyrights. There.
Timesaving service was developed by a
team of experienced attorneys and legal
zoom takes care of you
from start to finish.
Legal Zoom documents have been accepted
by courts and government agencies and
all 50 states. So it's totally
legit. Legalzoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect you to an attorney
and provide self help services at your
specific directions. So if you need
help, they're there to help you out.
They'll walk you through the whole
process for even more savings.
Enter [inaudible], B U R R and
the referral box at checkout. Um,
if you're a parent or or an entrepreneur,
don't wait any longer.
Call or visit legal zoom.com and
protect what's yours. Oh righty.
There's that.
And then of course,
what would a podcast be without a
stamps.com read everybody, come on.
You know the deal I use still a seriously,
I,
you still going to the post office
is still going down there unless you,
unless you like routinely where a brooch,
there's no reason why you should still be
going to the, you know, down to the Po,
uh, the post office, right?
The post office is always
crowded. Who's could know?
Okay, now it will be even more crowded
with people mailing in their taxes.
But you still need to get out envelopes
and packages for your businesses.
So use stamps.com instead,
hey bill,
what stamps.com stamps.com brings all
the services for the post office reits or
your desk.
Buy and print official US postage for
any letter or package using your own
computer and printer stamps.com
we'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates
the exact postage you need.
You'll never have to go
to the post office again.
stamps.com they're your friends.
It's so easy to use.
They're even a more unlike me can use it.
No wonder stamps.com printed over $1
billion in postage just last year alone.
I use stamps.com to send out all my
DVDs to all my fun little shows and I
absolutely love not having
to go there right now.
Use My last name bur bur
for this special offer,
a no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer
includes the digital scale and up to $55
in free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburpeeyouarerthatstamps.com
enter birth. All right,
back to the podcast.
Uh, Tom, ways to die. So man,
he dumb ways to die.
The fucking songs in my head.
I'm going to hook you guys up with a
youtube video and I know what already has
40 something million hits and people will
be like, wait to be on new gut nudge.
Oh Youtube
for all you dumb fucks out there.
40 million hits, 40 million people is
not even 1% of the world population.
Okay.
So any sort of of recommendation
for a goddamn video is fine.
All right. It go fuck yourselves.
Hey, what do you guys think
is worse? Uh, the, the,
the,
um,
Atlanta Braves fans doing that
Tomahawk Chop or red sox fans singing.
Sweet Caroline.
I'll let you think it over.
I have to be honest with you just because
it's offending of fucking group of
people that were victims of genocide.
I got to go with Tomahawk Chop,
but I have to say,
um,
sweet Caroline is a close second.
I mean,
that's literally stopped me from watching
fucking home games at the Boston Red
Sox, that and the whole steroid era.
I stopped watching it. 2010, you know,
once like fucking half the
red sox tested positive.
Was it really half bill or was it two or
three key guys? Two or three key guys,
you know,
and one guy,
oh think escape town via Chicago for
never fucking got caught for anything.
Um, that's just, you know, just
speculation. Pure speculation people.
But, um, yeah, so I was kind of at
that point I was like, all right,
they either need to make steroids legal
or get it out of the game because I'm
sick of getting excited
about shit. And then, uh,
four years later you're telling me
that it doesn't really count. You know,
I don't fucking know.
Um,
this is how long it's been since
I've watched the red sox game.
I'm looking at the USA Today sports page
and it's got a picture of a Boston red
sock who I don't even recognize and it
said Middlebrooks shows clout with three
home run day.
Evidently there's a guy in the red sox
called will Middlebrooks who was four for
five with three home runs in four rbis
Sunday and he's batting three 20 for the
season.
I have that guy could fucking,
yeah,
you can be sitting down next
to me in a fucking restaurant.
I'd have no idea who he was. I'd be
like, who's that really in shape?
Tire salesman.
He's not a tire sales me.
Why that stats fucking will Middlebrooks
okay.
Middlebrooks it's not
Middlebrook Middle Brooks.
Okay.
The Middlebrooks the middle.
Brock's family. Everybody.
Subsequently we got a guy
named will Middlebrooks.
I'll tell you right now if y'all,
you know I gotta tell Ya
from the Yankees right now,
I gotta be worried about
that will Middlebrooks.
MMM.
I don't even know what's,
I have no idea what's going well,
what is going on in baseball right now?
I,
they finally done building
all new stadiums and sing
a dumb ass fucking songs.
Just make the roids legal.
Okay.
Just let everybody take them and
then it'll, it'll be all right.
And then we'll all take them. Everybody
takes them. Everybody's jacked.
Everybody's got a short fucking temper,
you know? I guess that would suck, but no,
you don't do really get that
anymore. Well, Bill, who knows you.
It's not like you fucking read about it.
MMM.
Let's get it. Let's talk about a sports
that maybe I know a little bit about.
Let's talk about hockey.
I'm telling you fucking cunts right
now who roll your eyes at hockey.
First of all, if you don't want to be
a fat fuck, take up the game of hockey.
It's the, it's I'm telling you, I've
seen, I say this weekend and week out,
it is the greatest old man's sport.
There is all these fucking old white
dudes go out there and they still playing
fucking hoop. What happens?
They come in Monday,
they blew out the fucking Achilles,
you know,
constantly fucking up your
knees, your hips, your feet,
cause you'll run it up the court. Right?
And you got on your fucking Steve Jobs,
new balance. You know that the, the,
the official old white guy sneakers,
which I just bought a new pair of them
with the inserts. That's when you know,
you're old. I'm constantly
getting fucking hurt, right?
Okay.
Baseball.
Nobody plays baseball.
You play softball and that's just really
an excuse to get absolutely fucking
hammered and eat hot dogs.
You actually softball leagues,
you actually fucking gain weight playing
the fucking game. So that's no good.
Now you're walking around with
this big fucking gut, you know,
with your coaching shorts,
one size fits all.
You look like you're in your third
trimester, that's fucking out.
You sure as hell not going to play
football and any sort of capacity.
And that leaves hockey. Hockey is
great because you're running around,
but she had gliding,
you know,
I'm telling you,
you fucking workup and unbelievable sweat.
It's great hand eye coordination and uh,
I'm completely 100% so I don't
even go to the fucking gym anymore.
I just go out and I get involved in a
pickup game. I'm actually to the point,
I'm at the upper level of sucking.
I can actually stick in a little bit and
keep my head up before somebody takes
the puck away from me.
But I'm getting a good sweat
and it's a beautiful game.
Um,
you know,
it's funny they have all these different
drills and I've been skating with this,
a comic on Nick Craig,
who I fucking brought out on tour when
we went through a Wisconsin in fucking
Michigan and he was showing
me a couple of drills.
You went to one of these stick
time things and it's just,
there's no hockey drill that is
an absolutely fucking exhausting.
Every fucking one of them.
It's like you do three reps of it and you,
you feel like you're going to absolutely,
you're going to die. You know,
you ever see baseball players before
fucking game, just sort of limbering up,
you know, just tossing the
ball, flicking the wrist.
That's a fucking sport you want to play,
I think.
But then you gotta do you
gotta do it 162 fucking times.
I would love to get a
professional baseball player
on this podcast and just talk
to him about July and
August and like how much,
even though you're making
millions of dollars,
how much you want to kill yourself,
how many fucking times at that point
you've heard the song take me out to the
ball game 125 fucking times.
Jay,
Mary out go though game.
He just sitting there like,
I'm going to fucking kill myself and
you're standing out there in the Goddamn
son,
right?
And now you got to try to figure out
who this fucking guy is on the mound and
what the hell he's putting on
the Goddamn ball like baseball.
It to me is literally, it's like going
to math class every fucking day. I just,
I wouldn't have the,
there's no fucking way I could ever get
smart enough to play that game at any
sort of fucking level. I just can't,
like when you played football,
you just fucking walk up when you
just play. Right. I don't get to,
I guess you have to figure out
the guy across the line from you,
but not to the level of
that these guys have to,
yeah.
You know what I mean? Like maybe you
figured the guy out for part of the game,
they don't come in and you know all
of a sudden bringing a fucking new
cornerback out of nowhere.
They do that with these hitters.
All of a sudden you got a new fucking
picture. What the fuck is this guy doing?
What's his deal? What's his release
point? Can I pick it up? It's,
it's coming off his fingers. It's no
fucking way. There's no fucking way.
The only way I would ever make it
in professional baseball is if I,
if I was a really good third base coach,
I really knew how to
give the fucking signs.
That's the only way I could ever make it.
Even if I had the god given ability,
I don't have the mental
stamina to give a fuck.
When another guy comes like,
I just fucking did this.
I just figured out a guy, now you're
bringing in another guy. Fuck this game.
Fuck this.
I'm going to be an announcer.
Okay.
You know,
I'm going to say I stole this story from
a this morning cause they didn't get to
it on the, uh, the wonderful program,
the, uh, the regular guys here in Atlanta,
some fucking asshole spent over
200 grand on a star Trek Ray gun.
All right?
200 fucking grant over 200
grand from some rare ray gun,
I guess used on the Star Trek episode.
And this is why I want to know how
much crooked shit has the baby boom
generation done that they can afford
to throw their money around like that.
You have watched those Barrett Jackson
auctions and like a Mustang will come up.
Well this is an actual be,
this is the real deal.
We're gonna start the
bidding at honor and $80,000.
Who the fuck as 180
grand to buy a Mustang?
You know this sitting there fucking
been on those fucking Ferrari's come up,
that one from Ferris Bueller's
day off comes up, but whatever.
And then if they could spend like 9
million bucks on it too, right there,
you should be fucking thrown in a
black van and fucking take it down and
underneath the Pentagon and they
figured out what the fuck you did.
Where did you get your money?
Five.
They probably know you, you
know something. If you've got,
if you have enough money,
well you can blow 9 million bucks on a
god Damn Ferrari that you're not even
going to drive because it's
worth so much fucking money.
Your wife doesn't give you
shit at that point. You Ha,
you know people at the Pentagon,
right?
You walk into the Federal Reserve
and they shout out your name,
like your fucking norm on cheers.
That's all I think of when I
watched those auctions. I'm like,
this is all filthy fucking money.
Nobody has this kind of money.
Yeah.
Barrett Jackson.
Do you have see a rod there?
A Rod doesn't even have
that kind of money.
Yeah,
a Rod.
My favorite Yankee of all fucking time.
I Dunno. But any other red sox fans?
I'm sort of a former red sox fan.
I think eventually
they'll get back into him.
I kind of like last year where
they sucked in everybody, you know,
just kind of burn off all the pink hats,
you know? But now, like I said, good.
So everybody's jumping
back on the bandwagon.
I've got to figure out when's a good
time to jump back in with those guys,
you know?
MMM.
Anyways, you know what? I'd probably
do it this year. At this point.
It makes me feel bad as a fan that I don't
know who fucking or will Middlebrooks
or did you just get the new will?
Middlebrooks Jersey.
I have no fucking idea who
he is. This is terrible. Um,
anyways,
what the fuck was I just talking about?
Just talking about no one
people in the Pentagon.
Oh my favorite Yankee ball time.
Alex Rodrigues watching the Yankees,
trying to shame a rod into demanding a
trade has been one [inaudible] and him
not taking the bait,
you know,
sending him in the ninth inning of the
playoffs and he just stills just like, ah,
you know,
we want whatever's good for the tape.
Hey, New York Yankees, front
office, just settle in.
You're going to have to
pay him every fucking dime.
I bet that they have his contract out
on the dare fucking giant walnut tables.
Every fuck is walnut expensive? I
Dunno. Every God Damn Day just pouring,
they probably have a team of lawyers just,
just specifically designed to pour over
that guy's contract to try and figure
out how the fuck they can get out of this.
I swear to God,
if a rod was abroad and
fucking the Yankees,
what we're, we're, we're a,
we're his husband. All right.
This story where to already been on
the first 48 because a rod woulda got
whacked. That's Desta type of financial
fucking situation there. You know,
when the guy just is like, there's no
way out of this. I just have to kill her,
you know, which is always the
dumbest fucking move ever.
You know what I mean? You,
you're gonna, you're gonna go to
hell forever. If that Shit's true,
sons got to happen. Something has to
happen, I think, you know what I mean?
Cause some people get away with murder
so there has to be some sort of fucking
something.
Right.
Okay.
In another world
or do they just put that in your head?
Because if there really
was no ramifications,
they didn't make that shit up that people
would just be walking around killing
people.
Okay.
Can you imagine if you just had no
fucking conscience that you just did that?
Anybody who is just annoying you,
you just fucking killed them and you
were so good at it, you never got caught,
you know,
with that.
Could you still enjoy life?
I guess if you don't have a conscience?
I'm trying to think how many
people I would actually like.
Seriously what a killed. I don't think
I ever would have killed anybody.
It's an interesting question.
Nah, I don't think I could. Oh,
but there's been a few I'd want it to.
All right,
let's give us the questions this week
before I fucking start incriminating
myself. Um, when it rains,
it pours a redheaded bass did.
So I know this is going
to be a horrible email,
but I listened to your podcast every
fucking Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
or whenever you get it up here were you
guys stopped saying fucking Wednesday.
It's not even Tuesday.
It's late Monday.
You fucking wine and [inaudible]
for the last fucking time.
I take it Monday morning my time.
It's not about you. It's about me.
So go fuck yourselves fucking bitch
in about a free God damn podcast,
you guys.
The Internet is a bunch of whiny cunts.
Whiny on original content, by the
way. All right, you people out there,
you got to set up. You gotta
fucking step up your Twitter game.
Stop using StockX fucking lines.
I want the last three minutes, 28
seconds of my life back. It's just like,
isn't that the most
unoriginal fucking thing ever?
I just threw up in my mouth a little bit.
Like you've read that a
million fucking times on,
on fucking Twitter and
you're gonna write it again.
Let it like you're going to get a laugh.
Get Out.
Has anybody ever come up to you,
told you a fucking street joke and then
right after that told it the you again
now because it's only funny once,
but you fucking Twitter hacks the same.
Fuck that feeling when, wait, what?
That's like the fucking hacky tag.
Yeah,
same fucking people will then bitch that
there's no fucking original TV shit out
there. And then that just sees unoriginal
conch and you know, it's funny,
they're all,
they're just repeating shit that they've
heard and then they're all laughing
their fucking asses off at their
own shit. It's fucking annoying. Oh,
I forgot to bring up the hockey
thing while I was going to say, uh,
you know what's killing me right now is
I think because of the injuries that the
penguins have and the fact that the
fucking Bruins can't score more than two
goals a fucking game.
I actually think that the Canadians or
the team to beat right now in the east,
and it fucking kills me that those cons
are looking like they actually have a
shot at winning a cup this year because
there's nothing I enjoy more than the
fact that the Montreal Canadians
are just not a factor anymore,
but they're never going to be
a factor ever again. You know,
the way that they were. I mean, it's a
fucking 30 team league now, you know,
I mean, dominating a fucking six
team league. It's, it's really,
it's really the of all like, you know,
they look back at the Yankee Dynasty,
the Celtics, the fucking packers and
Steelers, and then the Canadians.
The Canadians is the most,
that one has the most fucking holes in it.
You know what I mean?
You dominated a 16 fucking Lee had to
beat five other fucking teams. Okay.
Four of which were in the
United States of America.
A country that could give
a flying fuck about hockey.
Nobody wanted it to be the
next rocket Ryszard down here.
They wanted to be the next Mickey Mantle.
Nobody gave a fuck.
So four out of the five teams, all you
had to be Pete was the maple leafs.
And in fact, up until 1967 as
far as Stanley cups went, it, uh,
the Canadians and the maple leaf for
going blow for blow. They didn't want the,
this is, this is how much hockey
didn't mean shit in this country.
I saw a story one time on,
um, on the NHL channel,
the radio morning radio program where
they were talking about how the rangers
finally made it to the Stanley Cup
finals and Madison Square Gardens.
So didn't give a fuck about hockey every
year they booked the circus in Madison
Square Garden during the time
when the Stanley Cup finals was.
So the fucking rangers make
it and they're like, fuck you,
we already have the circus. And
they're like, but wait a minute,
we're in the Stanley Cup.
And they go, yeah, but we got
elephants. Go Fuck Yourself.
So the Rangers had to
play their home games.
They put them in Toronto because they
were playing Detroit and they figured to,
Toronto was the closest, you know,
I guess, I dunno to fucking Detroit.
So maybe you'd get some
Toronto fans and hated Detroit.
I Dunno why they just didn't send them to
Chicago. Who the fuck knows? But that's,
that's, that's how much hockey meant,
you know, so that's what I'm saying.
I look at that dynasty like it's fucking
bullshit. Not Bullshit. I respect it,
but it's kind of like, you know. Okay.
Five other fucking teams. Wow. Did
you go on a run? That's amazing.
You had a one in five fucking chance
of winning it. How did you do it?
Um, so my name's bill. Hey, you read it at
best, so I know. Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Anyways,
um,
I've been riding on a high point for the
first time this month and I wanted to
get your opinion on this matter.
I was on a low point when it came to the
ladies and I couldn't bag a 300 pound
baldy for the life of me.
Okay.
Uh, baldy you're talking about
a woman here. Same with a fatty,
with a shade putsy what
are you talking about?
All of a sudden I've been landing every
hot broad I've been interested in for
the last past six months and I just
don't fucking get it. Well, don't,
don't overthink it.
It's like golf.
Don't get your head just
fucking swing away. Um,
how does it work that nothing about me
has really changed besides I bought a new
shirt and maybe did a few
more pull ups the normal,
but it just seems like when it's raining,
it's pouring pussy.
The women's smell it on you or what?
I'm not exaggerating this man.
I've landed two of the hottest girls
I've ever met in my entire life this past
two weeks.
I just wanted to ask the age old question,
why in the fuck does
this all happen at once?
Why can't life space this out?
So I can ride the wave for a year or two
and be happy instead of having it all
happen at once and life sucks eight
out of 12 months of the year. Um,
because getting pussies, it's like
playing golf. It's a fucking mental game.
All right, and if you have a bad shot,
you got to block the last one out.
It's like a relief pitcher.
He let up a home run. Fuck it.
Give me another ball and you just block.
You got to block it out.
But what happens is,
is you know,
you start to feel like you're in a slump
and then you get desperate and fucking
women just stay, smell it on
you. You come in in there,
you know you're trying too hard extra
splash, a cologne, you're, you're fucking,
you're right in their grill.
Like Louisville full court fucking press
your write up on that fucking pussy and
then that's it.
It's over.
They get all nervous and they
pick up the ball and they go home.
You know,
you can't give a fuck the only,
I've only golf a few times,
but like I don't keep score.
I refuse to give a shit about that sport
and I have a great time and everybody
else's fucking throwing their
clubs and getting all pissed off.
I don't give a fuck. I'm having
a great time. You know what?
I'm going for the hall.
I'm going for the pin,
you know,
I fucking
miss and I suck, but I'm having a
good time. That's all you gotta do.
You gotta go Phil Mickelson
on these bitches. All right.
They'll fucking trying to plot
and get par. Go for the Birdie.
You don't want, if you
miss it, who gives a fuck?
You got to stay in that zone
and not giving a shit, sir.
And even then you still going to, there's
going to be feet, feast or famine.
That's it's just how it is. If I
knew the answer to that, you know,
I would have done much better in my, uh,
my pathetic trying to get some career.
Um, all right. Book of job.
Okay.
God is the glory of Vegas.
Okay. Hey, hey belt.
Listening to the podcast and religious,
the religious douche giving his douchey
impression of the story of Joe pissed me
off. First of all, the phrase he got.
Yeah.
Jobbed is actually derived
from the story of job. Oh,
we just pronounce it right.
Is it, is it job or jobs?
I don't fucking know.
Here's why. First of all,
Christians condemned gambling and yet
hold bingo parties in the church parlors
every week. But the book of
job actually reveals that God,
God is all for gambling because not
only did God make the very first way,
Joe God was also the first pit boss
and heaven was the first casino.
I like where this guy's going.
Um,
the Bible story is that job was
so devastated to devote it to God.
Sorry that there was no way he
would ever curse God's name.
The devil went to heaven and said to God,
uh,
no shitty won't curse you. He's rich
as fuck. He's got a hot wife. Seven,
no non gay sons and three
great looking daughters.
Who Will,
who don't date?
Give me five minutes with that piece
of shit and I'll get him to curse you
upside down till next Tuesday.
And God said, uh, yeah,
you want to make no fucking way,
Jeff.
Okay.
See God, new job. God made job.
God knew 100% for certain that
he would win this, this bet.
Uh,
Bingo.
God is now the first casino boss because
God has an inside knowledge of the game.
God even gave the devil the odds.
So they shook on it and the devil goes
out fucking over, job's something fierce,
raped and killed his kids. Holy.
She kids raped and killed his kids,
really burned all his house and crops,
killed all his livestock. But the worst,
the devil essentially gave Joe Herpes,
but not just to job's wife.
Ah,
what the fuck to herpes,
but not to job's wife.
Try explain that to your wife without
at least cursing God a little under your
breath. But Joe never caved, so God
won the bet. Of course, God won.
It's God. God did give Joe
Ball his stuff back, but now,
but how stupid was the devil dead?
He bet against God.
Okay.
The same as all of us when we go to
Vegas and come out saying, I got jobbed.
Ah, Jesus Christ. That
was so fucking clever.
It made my fucking head burst.
I think you're absolutely right,
but I,
I just,
I got halfway through that story and
it's like there's no way that someone
wouldn't, wouldn't freak the
fuck out rate is fucking kids.
Why is the Bible's is so
fucking violent like that.
Okay.
And you just have to sit there and unlike,
you know why?
Because they want you to
be just completely 100%
devoted to the bullshit that
they're giving you.
That the invisible guys saying their
version of what the invisible guys saying
to the point that someone
can come and rape your kids,
burned down your houses and your
crops kill all your livestock.
And at no point you're not supposed to
be like God data at any point in that's
supposed to fucking say that.
Okay.
And if you don't,
God's going to give you everything back.
He isn't horrible shit happen to people's
families like that and the [inaudible]
and God doesn't come back and make it
fucking better, but fucking idiots. We'll,
we'll go to church and they'll hear that
fucking story and they will believe it.
Sorry.
So you mean you made a great but it almost
seemed like a very common one s kind
of bit there.
Um,
okay.
Sorry. It's just my fucking
opinion on a organized religion.
I get a little flustered. I get a
little hot under the collar, um,
law school or bust.
Hey bill loved the podcast.
Nobody really [inaudible] so my question
has to do with the law school. Um,
okay.
Oh with law school,
my brain is not fucking working today.
I'm going to be done my first year of
law school in three weeks and I hated it.
I have never found anything I like
to do in my life other than you.
The usual under achievable things
like my love for hockey and football.
I hate every job I've ever had and I
thought law school might be the answer but
it's not well but it's not bed.
I cannot stand law school and I cannot
stand the thought of the career in law.
These professors always talk about
all the rules, all the restrictions,
all the dealing face to face with
people's problems. It sounds exhausting.
It sounds not fun at all.
And I have zero enjoyment from it.
I already know the answer to your problems
here, sir. Or at least I feel I do. Uh,
you said,
my question is this,
my friends and family all say this is
just part of life. Nobody loves their job,
nobody likes school, et Cetera. But I
see these people who love their jobs.
I see people in my class that
loved their law school stuff.
I don't know whether I should stick it
out in school and just pray it grows on
me. The debts from law
school are insane. Um,
hope it grows on me like
everyone says it might.
Or should I take the plunge and
change direction completely.
Completely look for something
else that pulls my excitement.
I do not know what to do and it weighs on
me daily. Thanks. And go fuck yourself,
dude. You're ignoring your
inner voice, which is saying,
I don't like this shit. Okay.
And what you're going to,
but it's a safe way to go.
You get a law degree, you get,
you become a partner, right?
And all of a sudden you make money
and you fucking hate your life.
And you know what,
you're going to bring that home to your
wife and your kids and you're going to
be an asshole husband and father and
because you hate your fucking job.
All right? Or You could
possibly do that. Who knows?
You could come home and just fucking
leave it at the front door. Look too.
All right. You said you have a
love for hockey and football.
Do you know how many
fucking jobs there are?
Yeah.
Why don't you go into that?
You know,
if you're going to stick with law school,
I become a sports agent so you
at least around it. But, um,
if I was into hockey or
football, I don't know. I would,
I would try to get into broadcast
and get into journalism.
Um, maybe become a sports
trainer or something.
There's all kinds of jobs at the cup.
Highschool where can weigh up to college
and all that type of shit. You know,
I would go that route.
If you like sports and you're into that,
you know that this,
this philosophy by a lot of people who
don't go after their fucking dreams,
that if you, if you, that
those aren't real jobs.
Like getting an in,
in any sort of entertainment or having
any sort of any exciting fucking job.
Like it'd be, I don't know, be one of
those, those Whitewater rafting guides,
those fucking people you know,
who get all kinds of fucking pussy because
he got these people who this is their
one week vacation from the job they hate
and they see this person who is totally
free love and life, you know, women.
Oh my God, that looks, that looks fun.
I needed inside me.
Right?
We've seen they're getting banged up
against some rock right next to the cores
fucking factory.
Um,
that's what I would do, sir. You
sign absolutely fucking miserable.
It seems like you love
hockey and football.
So I would try and find a job in hockey
and football and I know that sounds
fucking insane, but you know, so
was telling jokes for a living.
I wasn't the funniest guy in high school.
I was funny, but I wasn't the funniest.
I just went to a fucking open mic and I
turned everything that I used to get in
trouble for until now I make money and
now I'm here in Atlanta two feet from a
fucking airport, breathing in jet fuel,
going to go to the NCAA championship game.
Cause I tell jokes for fucking living.
You too sir, can live your dream.
If a dumb fuck like me could do it,
you can do it too.
It sounds like you absolutely fucking
hate being in being in law school.
All right.
Okay.
It's going to be terrible dude.
Then you become a lawyer and
then because you hate it,
you're going to be looking for a big
score. You know when you get to do some,
you know,
some sort,
some sort of corruptible fucking thing
to get your fucking money so you can
parachute your way out of there.
You can be sitting in you stupid
office with your cufflinks.
See a little tie tech just
counting down the days,
you know to when fucking have a vacation.
Dude,
you're going to be a trial lawyer and
somebody is freedom is going to be on the
line and you're not going to
have any fucking passion for,
you're going to be sitting
across someone going, oh my God,
if I listened to listen
to one more person,
tell me that drugs were planted
on them. I mean, I've telling you,
don't fucking do it. All right? You
can have a fun job and make money.
It's one of the biggest fucking lies
that's told by the generation. And,
and you know, if your parents are fucking
miserable and they hate their job,
they don't know.
They don't know.
So that's telling you what they know
that you know what? Life's tough.
And you go and you'll sit
there and you hit the books.
You have this fucking miserable fucking
existence. You don't have to do it.
Look at all these fucking
people writing blogs.
He's fucking people out there
who like they're into food.
I'm a foodie and they
go around and Oh my God,
the apple had a so much sediment
on it and they take pictures of it.
It makes me know they've
got an advertising and then
making money sitting there
in the fucking pajamas, eating fruit
loops, reviewing it, making money.
You can't make money in
fucking hockey and football.
I, you're, you're out of
your fucking mind, sir.
Yeah,
I felt the weight of your fucking life
reading that thing. All right. So please,
for the love of God,
for all the innocent men that you're going
to defend halfheartedly in the future,
please tap out of that fucking industry
and go someplace that you give a fuck.
All right? And that's it,
sir. And you know what?
That's one to grow on a meet and greets.
Hey Bill,
I'm curious what you think about the meet
and greet, taking pictures, et Cetera,
with people who attend your shows.
Is it completely awkward?
I fucking hate that word.
Stop using that word.
Such a fucking overly used God damn
word and the whole fucking generation,
the sun is shining awkward, laughing
my ass off, shaking my head, tweet.
Um,
do you enjoy it?
Is it nice to hear people tell you how
funny you are or does it just become
ridiculous? I see pictures
that fans take with artists.
And I always wonder if
the artists are thinking,
kill me now or if they appreciate someone
wanting to take a picture with them in
that setting, have a great
day and go fuck yourself. Um,
the meet and greet is like doing a
whole other show. If you're tired,
it's a fucking pain in
the ass. Um, but you know,
if you go out there, you, you, you know,
you put a fucking smile on your face
and you take pictures with people. Um,
it's really what it is. What makes it
exhausting is, is 15% of the people,
85% of fucking cool.
It's the 15% that are
fucking hammered and, uh,
this slapping you on the back and if
or they've got their fucking sweaty,
there's a bunch of like,
you know, I understand why,
how he Mendell does the fist bump.
But, um, generally speaking, you
know, I like going out there.
I like going out there and
having people say, Hey, you know,
I had a bad day and listen to the podcast.
And I've had people come up to me and say,
you know,
their mom has cancer and like, she
watched all three of your specials and,
and you know, it put a smile on her
face. I mean, that, that's like,
that's worth going out there and
dealing with, you know, when, you know,
one of my pet peeves is when somebody
is much taller than me as a guy and they
put their arm around
me and they're sweaty.
Fucking warm armpit is resting on one
of my shoulders. I fucking hate that.
All right. But, you know,
it makes it worth it when you hear
stories like that or you got, you know,
people who are going off to
war or came back or whatever,
and they say they listen to you
a joke. So it's, there's always,
there's always a couple of
cool conversations that, uh,
that makes it worth it. Um,
what makes it annoying is when people
don't have their cell phones ready or they
hand them to somebody
they don't even know,
and then they don't know
how to use the phone.
And then they get upset because this
complete stranger doesn't know how to use
this phone. That's not even
theirs. And, um, at that point,
you already have your arms around these
complete strangers and then that gets a
little weird. Uh, but you know,
it's a part of it, you know,
you don't like fucking doing that,
then, uh, you know, don't, don't, uh,
don't jump on stage. You know,
it's how I look at it. I mean,
sometimes I don't go out there.
If I'm fucking exhausted and
I feel like I'm getting sick,
I won't go out there because,
you know,
I'm going to go out to a shaken all
these fucking hands and I'm getting
everybody's germs all over me.
Then I'm going to get sick and then my
next show is going to suck because I'm
going to be sick. And it's,
you know, I had, that's the,
my first obligation is you
paid a ticket to see me.
Give you a great fucking show.
And if I don't do that,
mmm.
You know, what's the point? All
right. So there you go. All right.
Single man advice. Oh, I'll still, but
I gotta be honest with you too. Um,
when I first used to go out there,
you mean it's a skill to know how
to actually talk and interact.
It's like a whole new skill
you have to learn. So, um,
I wasn't good at it at first.
MMM.
I just be like, hey, how are you?
Did you like the show? You know,
I was really bad at it and um,
through launching certain people
who are just naturally good at it,
like I always thought Dane
was really good at it. Um,
yeah,
Kevin Hart,
I thought it was really just naturally
good at it and I would just kind of watch
how they interacted with people and uh,
okay.
Tried to use that as a,
I don't know,
it was a guideline on how to
fucking do it, you know? So anyways,
but I have to admit like it, people
never used to do that. Like the, the,
the interaction that
you guys have now with,
with people that you see it shows is
fucking insane. You know, I went to,
I went to a no doubt concert and
she was like taking pictures,
like grabbing people's cell phones
and taking like fucking selfies,
I guess is what they call them
with people in the fucking crowd.
And I actually found that annoying.
It's like I came here to see you guys.
All right.
You know,
I know now you have to kiss the crowds
ass to like some fucking unbelievable
level. But I just think it
like knocks down. It's like
you're a fucking rock star.
Be a rock star. You should
be that accessible. You know?
I don't fucking know what, whatever.
Here we go. Single man advice. Hi Bill.
Uh, okay. Me Just Bill. Maybe
a little more than that.
No, just bill. I'm keeping the intro
simple. I'm single and need advice.
I don't know what soup to choose.
I'm really fond of clam chowder or
these euphemisms for different kinds of
women. Really Fun of Clam Chowder,
right? So you're like a pasty redhead,
but know that chicken
noodle soup would be better.
Paint the picture of the
classic bachelor role. What?
Okay,
you guys,
why do you guys leave out like four words
in a row and just make me sound even
dumber than I am.
Okay.
Which soup would look better spilled
on the plain white t shirt also.
I just cleaned my apartment after
letting the dust build for a while.
Is this a problem? Thanks for the
advice. Thanks for any advice.
It worked. Single man advice I've do. I
really have to answer this fucking thing,
which we'll look to.
Clam chowder is like Crustacean Jizz
Clam Chowder is fucking disgusting.
It's fucking gross. It's
like lobster puke. Ah,
it's just warm at that chunks is shit.
Now all the women are turning this up,
but it's fucked.
Clam chowder is,
it's octopus Jizz.
Okay.
An octopus that's taking Propecia and is
having a reaction to it and that's what
those jumps are. Um, chicken noodle soup.
Come on, man. That's hard.
That's good stuff. That broth
is barely going to show up.
They would, if you
fucking, you know, if yeah,
you get clam chowder on your tee shirt,
people are going to think you took
a fucking hot one to the face.
Dribbled off you'd goddamned Chin.
Wow. Disgusting Lobster Puke,
Octopus,
ges,
and then a fucking male on male
facial to end the fucking podcast.
How do you like that up right there.
Fucking two point minus two points.
So the desk mount, um,
I think that that is,
I mean we are we going to end with that?
Let's type some of my shows here.
Everybody. Um, oh by the way, by the way,
I almost forgot to bring up
the hard copy version of you.
People are all the same for all
the old school media consumption,
summers,
whatever the fuck you say out there.
If you're old school like me and
if you really like something,
you just don't want to download it.
I don't like doing that cause I, I,
if I can't fucking hold on to it,
you know, it's in the air man.
I don't fucking like that
stuff where you know,
it's on my iTunes and it's in,
it's in, it's on my fucking, uh,
my phone or my iPod or whatever.
I don't like that shit because of those
things all die back in the day when you
stereo died, you didn't lose
your whole record collection too.
So I am a big fan if you like to have,
it's like having the gold
behind you money. All right.
If you'd like a hard copy version,
either come out and see me live
or a buy one off of the website.
It's right underneath where,
uh,
you can either download it for five bucks
for the kids, that's the snowboarders.
And if you still ski, if you're old
school and you want the hard copy,
it's available bill bird.com right
on the merchant page. And uh,
slowly but surely I am working
on some podcasts, tee shirts.
Um, and that is it. That's the
podcast for this week. Let's, uh,
let's quickly go to
[inaudible] dot com here.
Who Do you guys liking the game tonight?
Hodie alike.
I have family from the Midwest, some kind
of pulling from Michigan, but you know,
Louisville has got the
whole broken leg story.
So I don't know who to vote for
here, who to root for. But, um,
I have to tell you that,
that Michigan seems to win on talent.
You know, like, I kind of fucked
they beat Syracuse was beyond me
because Syracuse had this insane fucking
zone defense and they will all the way
out by the three point line. So
immediately I'm thinking, what?
Just fucking fast break.
Don't let him get set up.
Don't let the ball touch the fucking
court. Do some Magic Johnson, showtime,
Lakers Shit.
Get it up there and get some easy fucking
layups and make them adjust to your
fucking game.
And they didn't,
they would just dribble it up the court
and let these fucking guys get set up.
Okay.
They couldn't beat the double team. Like,
I feel like Michigan is getting, like,
because they're so young,
they just kids,
I really feel that they're just kind
of getting away on raw talent and now
they're going up against Rick Pitino
who's just a monster coach. Um, I
think Louisville is going to take it.
That's what I think.
But my hat,
I'll be rooting for Michigan
hail to the victors value in,
you know, I also like Ohio. Hi. Oh state.
That's because I come from Massachusetts.
We don't really have any pro shit other
than Doug Flutie fucking stupid share
went down again. Fucking con.
All right, so this is the deal.
I'm going to be at the Georgia theater
in Athens, Georgia. April knife.
Um, I'll be at the comedy club at the
Star Dome. Hoover, Alabama. April 10th.
I'll be in Charleston music hall.
April 11th,
I'll be at the tabernacle for not one,
but two shows Friday night in Atlanta,
Georgia. April 12th. And then I got two
shows at the Improv in Tampa on Monday.
I think those are already
sold out. Um, April 16th,
I have two shows at Florida
State University and April
17th and met the Jackie
Gleason Fillmore theater
in Miami, Florida. Uh,
later on this month I'll be in
Dallas, Austin, Texas, Kansas City.
I got a Gig in Las Vegas and anybody who
wants to escape an unhappy marriage and
see me at the Mirage will be
there on May 17th and 18th. Um,
all my dates are up on billboard.com.
Thank you to everybody who's
been listening to the podcast.
Our numbers have been
growing thanks to uh,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast for
always giving shout outs and links to my
podcast. And I'm, if you listen
to the j more sports show,
I'm going to be calling
that in today at 1130, uh,
am Pacific standard time. Uh, that is it.
That's the podcast for this week. Go fuck
yourselves. I'll talk to you next week.